und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka abend
wind und regen künstlich ist das ja
eigentlich nicht hält aber viele nicht
davon ab endlich mal wieder draußen zu
sitzen bei kaffee oder bier und
passender mahlzeit dazu da draußen sein
bei jeder wetterlage haben wir uns ja
gewöhnt so viele spaziergänge viele
letzten 14 monaten hat so manch einer
vielleicht in seinem ganzen leben noch
nicht gemacht aber jetzt wieder sitzen
und nicht nur auf parkbänken sondern auf
den terrassen von restaurants und es
kommt sogar jemand und den bestellungen
auf was früher selbstverständlich war
ist jetzt ein richtiges erlebnis
bevor wir uns gleich anschauen wie es in
deutschland an diesem pfingstwochenende
zugeht fasst christian von rechenberg
noch kurz einige aktuelle meldungen
zusammen in unserem corona ticker
zum ersten mal gibt es in deutschland an
einem tag mehr zwei impfungen als
erstimpfungen das meldet das robert koch
institut insgesamt sind natürlich
deutlich mehr menschen einmal geimpft
momentan 40 prozent der bevölkerung
[Musik]
ebenfalls meldet das lka aktuell 7082
corona neuinfektionen 812 weniger als
vor einer woche die inzidenz sinkt auf
66,8 im zusammenhang mit dem virus gab
es 170 weitere todesfälle
[Musik]
ihrem digitalen impfpass erhalten sie
sobald er kommt ob womöglich auch in der
apotheke
18.000 apotheken gibt es in deutschland
ein großer teil so ihr verband nehme
sich der aufgabe an
politiker prophezeien uns ja immer
häufiger einen sehr guten sommer nun
auch der vize der eu-kommission frans
timmermans er sei zuversichtlich dass
wir europäer wieder einen relativ
normalen sommer urlaub machen könnten
ja das wollen wir doch gern einen
kleinen vorgeschmack auf urlaub und
normalität konnte man heute schon in
hamburg und umgebung bekommen dort ist
die sieben tage ins ident inzwischen auf
35 gesunken unter den bundesländern
liegt nur schleswig-holstein noch
niedriger und so herrschte heute hoch im
norden stimmungsmäßig ein hauch von côte
d'azur nur das wetter musste man sich
noch zu denken martini sind berichtet
das erste frisch gezapfte bier seit mehr
als einem halben jahr hamburg macht auf
und parkplätze zu biergärten bei 14 grad
und schmuddelwetter der wird ist
allerdings etwas aus der übung
alltäglichen sachen bieten da muss man
sich wahrscheinlich wieder ein bisschen
rein wachsen weil man das ja ewig lang
nicht gemacht hat sieben monate kein
bier gezapft aber ich denke dass
fahrradfahren oder schwimmen also
irgendwann vorzeichen apropos wieder
kommen zum ersten mal seit mitte
dezember hat modedesignerin sarah
tehrani wieder kundinnen in ihrem
kleinen laden
war auch echt ganz schön nervig shoppen
ohne test pflicht in der hamburger
innenstadt bilden sich schon am morgen
lange schlangen vor den geschäften ein
lichtblick im nieselregen
die wirtschaftlichen sorgen für das was
in den vergangenen 14 monaten passiert
ist das ist ja jetzt mich mit einem mann
streich weg aber es sind wahnsinnig
viele optimisten die geschäfte betreiben
und wir gucken heute alle hoffnungsvoll
nach vorne hochbetrieb auch auf dem auto
shuttle nach sylt die nordseeinsel ist
nahezu ausgebucht trotz des pflicht
regen und ziemlich steifer brise
endlich mal wieder da ist ja und sie
hierhin selbst wenn wir dabei geben
wetter schön unsere frische luft dass
das wichtigste alles gut im baden
württembergischen rust hat der europa
park als modellprojekt geöffnet mit
strengen hygiene auflagen und
reduzierter besucherzahl viel vergnügen
für die gäste viel stress für management
und mitarbeiter natürlich freue ich mich
wenn man so lange geschlossen waren
natürlich gibt es jetzt eine perspektive
aber da braucht es noch ein paar jahre
dass ich mich wirklich auf wann gewöhnen
kann in potsdam in brandenburg ist das
wetter morgen zwar besser und auch marie
okabe ist froh dass er wieder gäste auf
der restaurantterrasse begrüßen darf
aber er sieht auch dunkle wolken am
horizont was passiert wenn es jetzt
gleich anfängt zu regnen und es fängt an
zu stürmen der gast darf auf keinen fall
noch drin und wenn er nicht auch nach
drinnen gehen darf dann bin ich ja nicht
mehr richtig gastgeber sondern da muss
ich sagen ja leute ihr bleibt ja schön
draußen sitzen mit eurem schnitzel
spargel vielleicht sind hamburgerinnen
und hamburger wettertechnisch weniger
verwöhnt die kneipe sonnenseite war auf
jeden fall gut besucht auch ohne sonne
mit dem start der urlaubssaison wollen
auch die kreuzfahrtschiffe auslaufen
manch einer mag das vielleicht
befremdlich finden auf solchen
ozeanriesen gab es ja zu beginn der
pandemie heftige krone ausbrüche und man
erinnert sich noch gut an die
kreuzfahrer die bangen mussten wer sie
überhaupt an land lässt das erinnerte
damals schon fast an alte seemannslieder
stichwort solche an bord und das soll
jetzt auch schon wieder los gehen ja
tatsächlich stark heute abend ein erstes
schiff der aida flotte von kiel aus in
see weitere sollen folgen ganz so wie
früher wird der betrieb aber erst mal
nicht laufen berichtet heike kruse
so hört sich erleichterung an die crew
darf wieder arbeiten die passagiere
können endlich wieder an bord nach mehr
als einem jahr zwangspause heute die
kreuzfahrt
[Musik]
die entspannte corona lage in schleswig
holstein macht es möglich schlange
stehen bei miesem wetter kreuzfahrt fans
wissen wofür wir
sind hier auf dem schiff und hier dann
dürfen wir wieder an der bar sitzen
schön in der gaststätte sitzen ob ich
ins restaurant gehe oder ob schiffe sind
alle durch getestet und kriegen jetzt
gleich ins breiten test und ich denke da
werden wir spaß aber vor dem spaß kommen
der test und die händedesinfektion für
die ganze familie auf see wird das so
weitergehen das motto entspannter urlaub
durch strenge regeln
ich fühle mich an bord ehrlich gesagt
sogar noch sicherer als ein land in bei
uns sind wirklich 100 prozent alle leute
getestet diesen umständen wird es an
land niemals geben und wir haben also
ein komplettes labor an bord und sind in
der lage pcr test und antigen test an
bord durchzuführen und auch unser
medizinisches personal ist in der anzahl
deutlich erhöht worden aufatmen auch an
land denn jeder kreuzfahrt touristen
normalerweise im schnitt 36 euro in der
innenstadt aus und der kieler hafen
hofft wieder auf eine rosigere zukunft
wir haben normalerweise so 2,4 2,5
millionen passagiere in einem jahr und
im letzten jahr waren es noch 500.000
passagiere durch die krise haben wir
natürlich einen starken einbruch
erlitten aber ich denke dass es
vorübergehend und langfristig denke ich
haben wir gute perspektiven der nächste
kreuzfahrer wartet schon auf der anderen
hafenseite dort geht es morgen los an
bord wird alles reisefertig gemacht zum
üblichen deck schrubben kommt natürlich
die desinfektion in diesen zeiten in den
kabinen hat das hygiene konzept optisch
etwas von schädlingsbekämpfung aber dem
zufall vielmehr dem virus soll nichts
überlassen werden
haben auch neue crew mitglieder gekriegt
unser clubs sind in quarantäne zu
gehen und danach dürfen sie natürlich
arbeiten und hier also aber es ist alles
wunderbar für
besonders auf
die route beider schiffe rüben kattegat
skagerrak landgang ist aus
sicherheitsgründen noch nicht vorgesehen
aber es gibt ein schönes wort dafür
blaue reise auf der grauen ostsee
viele infos rund ums coroner thema
finden sie wie immer bei uns natürlich
auch online auf zdf jetzt heinz da geht
es mit dem krone thema auch als noch mal
weiter zwei demonstrationen von gegnern
der korona politik an diesem wochenende
in berlin sind verboten worden und die
gerichte dort haben das bestätigt heute
versammelten sich im stadtzentrum
mehrere hundert menschen um gegen die
korona maßnahmen zu protestieren
überwiegend ohne abstand und masken die
polizei löste die zusammenkünfte auf
erteilte platzverweise und sperrte den
bereich ums brandenburger tor großräumig
ab
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat deutliche
kritik geübt an antisemitischen
vorfällen bei demonstrationen der
letzten tage in ihrer wöchentlichen
videobotschaft sagte sie wer hass gegen
juden auf die straße tragen wer
volksverhetzende beleidigende
begriffe
norden wie die polizei mitteilte
beleidigten drei unbekannte den mann der
eine kippa trug im stadtteil schöneberg
eine habe ihm dann mit der faust ins
gesicht geschlagen und in antisemitisch
beleidigt der verletzte musste im
krankenhaus behandelt werden der
polizeiliche staatsschutz ermittelt
bundesbildungsministerin carlitscheck
hat angekündigt dass der lernstand der
schüler überprüft werden soll wegen der
schwierigen unterrichtssituation in der
korona pandemie und wegen des geplanten
nachhilfe programms wie sie dem
deutschlandfunk sagte könnte das loch
vor den sommerferien in form ähnlich wie
klassenarbeiten erfolgen der
lehrerverband habe gesagt 20 bis 25
prozent der kinder seien substanziell
wirklich betroffen lücken zu haben jetzt
so carlitscheck müsse man identifizieren
wer die betroffenen sind
nachdem großbritannien ja frisch zum
virusvarianten gebiet erklärt worden ist
wegen der indischen mutante hat der
ärmelkanal nochmal etwas breiter
geworden zu sein vom black cit ganz zu
schweigen werden wir uns von den briten
entfremden oder sie sich von uns zum
glück kann die kunst ja immer eine
brücke sein der bildhauer tony cragg ist
so ein brückenbauer nein britta wohnhaft
in wuppertal die liebe zog ihn in den
70er jahren dort mehrere jahre war er
rektor der kunstakademie düsseldorf
die queen schlug ihn zum ritter der exit
trieb ihn dazu die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft anzunehmen er ist ein
wanderer zwischen den welten und einer
der großen der kunstwelt wie er seine
neueste ausstellung in england aus dem
deutschen home office in wuppertal
dirigierte erzählt diana zimmer
reisende aus deutschland tony cragg
skulpturen haben es über den canal
geschafft und tragen nun in den himmel
über
norwegen cockpit konnte der bildhauer
selbst nicht mitreisen er hat die
ausstellung aus seiner wahlheimat
wuppertal
mitgestaltet dieses kulturen
sie sehen fast so aus sollten sie sich
nicht benehmen also die sind ein ganz
anderer verrückte energie müsse augen
drauf halten falls du etwas anstellen
mit hilfe einer magnettafel hat craig
seine werke in horten hall ferngesteuert
im 18 jahrhundert lebte hier
großbritanniens erster premierminister
heute ist es eine spielwiese für
bildhauer
das ist ein markt stellt man in seine
ganze geometrien in seines situieren er
ist ein diese gerade linien die waren so
große wisst es ermöglichen das ist das
ist power und in diese situation dann
auch skulpturen meine skulpturen
einzubauen das ist ganz andere energie
das ist ein
institutionelles mach statement in
künstler sind nur individuen
in jungen jahren arbeitete der brite mit
gefundenem material
treibgut schrott doch um neue formen und
mit ihnen gedanken in die welt zu
bringen verwendet er nun zuverlässigeres
plastik gusseisen bronze
inspiration zieht er immer noch aus der
natur seine werkstatt zeugt von einem
unruhigen geist
wird das glaube ich für alle künstler
die ich kenne es ist fast ein
24-stündiger befassen damit das ist
irgendwas wo man nie los kommt und
klassik
im gesellschaft oder mitten in der nacht
oder in die badewanne immer eine ewig im
moment
hat man irgendwie so die die hunde
vorstellen man kann das nicht in ruhe
lassen
alles auch und gerade emotionen sind für
craig material
selbst mit 72 jahren wandert er noch
staunend durch die welt das leben ist
etwas
wahnsinniges ein wunder in ein etwas
außergewöhnlich denkendes machen fühlen
das material zu sein in ein wiesn
universum das ist was man darf also man
könnte religiös werden dabei aber ich
bin wild habe
das jüngste werk in worten holz stammt
aus dem coro naja masken heißt die
branche diese wecken wie cracks werke
überhaupt den natürlichen drang unter
ihre oberflächen zu blicken
in der fußball-bundesliga stand ja schon
vor dem letzten spieltag fest dass
bayern münchen meister ist in der
abstiegszone fehlen aber heute noch
entscheidungen werder bremen muss ebenso
wie schalke in die zweite liga köln ist
auf dem relegationsplatz mehr dazu
gleich im aktuellen sportstudio jetzt
die lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
38 17 38 40 43 superzahl 2 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und wie zdf text auf seite 55 6
und jetzt zum wetter mit aussichten von
sonne bis zu gewittern morgen im westen
und südwesten längere zeit sonnig später
dann auch im süden im norden immer
wieder schauer und auch einzelne
gewitter im tagesverlauf freundlicher 12
bis 19 grad am montag vor allem im osten
und süden freundlich dabei bis 23 grad
danach aber wieder wechselhaft mit
schauern und gewittern und dazu auch
erneut kühler
das war für uns wie gesagt die kollegen
vom sportstudio freuen sich schon
absehen und um 0 15 danach gibt es die
nächste heute express bis morgen wieder
[Musik]